so recently I did a little collaboration
with Dodie Clark where we sung one of my
old songs it was really fun and it
really got me in the mood to do some
more songs myself I haven't written a
song in like two years so I'm probably a
little bit out of practice as a song
that I've written is also from the
perspective of my cat so don't expect
anything too deep but I hope you'll join
under less oh what a wonderful day
to eat and sleep and sleep and eat and
play
hey let me give you a clue
if you can smell that smell then please
clean up my I know you just fed me but I
am still hungry
so I think I'll chew on this cardboard
in lieu I was all your need until you
hear my plea please don't ignore me
don't you love your kitty oh I know that
I'm not always the best cat I run in
circuits fool around your flats I take
my naps on the damp bath mat the sofas
my favorite thing to scratch ants but
I'm pretty cute and I'm fluffy too boobs
oh I may be smelly but rub my belly you
fill my heart with glee as you belong to
me
I'm sure you'll give me all I ask for
don't you know it's true I've got you
under my not yet I'll tell you when you
can bet okay you can scratch me now now
stop now please scratch me again I know
that I shed my head absolutely
everywhere and I know it's hard to
ignore when I knock all your things on
floor and I can hear you II when I won't
let you sleep oh but isn't it just so
sweet we are all over at your feet oh I
know that I'm not always the best cat I
run in circuits pull around your platter
take my naps on the damp earth matha
sofas my favorite thing to scratch ants
but I am pretty cute and I'm fluffy to
boot so I may be smelly but rub my belly
and fill my heart with glee is you
belong to me
oh you belong to me now that that is
finished and I am sitting here sweating
my pants off got a few things I want to
talk to you about number one Emily's
short film that I edited cold it's out
now so please do give that a watch I'm
incredibly proud of Emily for making a
movie and feel really lucky that I've
got to work on it and speaking of short
films the post is for mine designed by
Johnny Epson and now all finished and
are up for sale on dftba.com so if you
like look at those they are now
available to you and if you buy all four
you get one free how about that and if
you buy all four you get one free that's
a deal what a deal okay thank you for
watching see you next time goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching if you'd like to see
my previous video I put it up there and
if you'd like to see that little
collaboration I did with Dodie I'll put
it down here ah oh my leg is gone to
sleep baby oh yeah let's go sleep oh
that really hurts what am I going to do
I think you can see my legs anyways it's
okay yeah